الازمات تتفاقم هنا في شمال قطاع غزه في
ظل اشتداد هذه الحرب واشتداد الحصار هنا
الاهالي يخرجون منذ ساعات الصباح للبحث عن
مصدر للمياه في ظل انعدام المياه بالكامل
هنا في شمال قطع غزه بسبب قصف الاحتلال
جميع الابار وجميع محطات التحليه هناك
ازمه تتفاقم يوما بعد يوم مع اشتداد هذه
الحرب كما نشاهد هنا الاطفال والاهالي منذ
الصباح يبحثون ويتجولون عن مصدر للمياه في
ظل انعدام المياه في شمال قطع غزه بالكامل
كما نشاهد هنا الاهالي يصطفون
لساعات بعدما وجدوا مصدر للمياه عند هذا
المنزل المدمر وتحت ركام هذا المنزل وجدوا
مصدر للمياه كما نشاهد يصطفون لساعات من
اجل الحصول على جزء بسيط من المياه والله
انا جيت قطعت مسافات طويله عشان اعبي
لاولادي ميه ولقيت البر هنا وعبت من الريش
هنا تحت المنزل المدم ر لقينا بربيش ميه
وعبيان منه ميه احنا لما بدنا ميه بنلاقي
صعوبه يعني بصحى من الساعه خسه الصبح على
سبت نبحث على ميه بتلاقي عين مي ونعبي
منها يعني في صعوبه كبيره كبيره كثير يعني
قاعد عن ذلك المسافه اللي بنقطعها بنلاقي
صعوبه يعني احنا يعني ان شاء الله بنطالب
انه يتوفر المي والغذاء للناس حتى يعيشوا
وال ايش وضع ماساوي قد ما تتصور ايش بدك
في هالوضع اللي احنا فيه جوع ما تسالش
الاولاد صيحوا كمان هاتو على نقمه خبز
طحين فشه شش بدك من وضع
زي الاطفال
عيات انجبت الاولاد من قل الميه من الوضع
الماساوي اللي احنا عايشين فيه انا بمشي
لاثه كيلو من شان اصل للميه في الوقت اللي
احنا كمان الجوع نساه والميه هذه غير
صالحه وهي من تحت ردم فميه غير صالحه ومع
ذلك متكيفين الى هذا الوضع كل ما بنيجي
هنا بلاقي طبو من هنا و والتوك توك هذاك
بلحقش
نعبي ولما نيجي نعبي بنيجي من 6 الصبح
اقلش هذا يا بنيجي على الخامسه لما بنيجي
نعبي بقوللك صوف دور نصوف دور بنا يمكن
ثلاث ساعات هكذا هو حال الاهالي هنا في
شمال قطع غزه في ظل انعدام كامل للمياه
وصعوبه في الحصول على هذه المياه وايضا
هذه المياه غير صالحه للشرب او للاستخدام
الا انهم اضطروا لاستخدام بسبب قصف
الاحتلال جميع الابار وجميع محطات التحليه
هناك صعوبه ايضا في نقل المياه الاهالي
يمشون لمسافات طويله من اجل البحث عن هذه
المياه انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه